dice el cuadrado debajo representa un
entero entonces este cuadrado grande
representa un entero expresa el área de
color como una fracción y como un
decimal así que veamos
hemos tomado aquí este entero y lo
dividimos en uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve diez secciones
iguales cada una de estas filas o cada
uno de estos rectángulos representa una
décima de un entero porque tenemos diez
secciones iguales en las que se dividió
este este cuadrado entonces cada uno de
estos rectángulos representa una décima
y bueno veamos están coloreados 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 están coloreados 8 de estas
décimas ahora si yo quisiera
representarlo como una fracción
diría que esto es ocho décimas
y si lo quiero representar como un
decimal tengo 0 enteros
y tengo ocho décimas entonces como
decimal sería 0.8 hagamos otro ejemplo
veamos aquí dice el cuadrado grande
debajo representa un entero expresa el
área de color como una fracción y como
un decimal entonces veamos que tenemos
aquí tenemos 10 filas y en cada una de
estas filas tengo 10 cuadrados entonces
tenemos 10 x 10 tenemos 100 cuadrados en
total quiere decir que dividían y entero
en 100 partes iguales eso quiere decir
que cada uno de estos cuadros representa
una centésima ajá así que bueno aquí
tenemos coloreados tenemos 12 33 de las
100 centésimas entonces tengo 3
centésimas lo escribo y como fracción
tres centésimas lo puedo escribir como
3 sobre 100 eso es tres centésimas y
como decimal bueno pues no tengo ningún
entero
no tengo décimas y tengo tres centésimas
hagamos un par de ejemplos más dice
expresa la posición del punto en la
recta numérica como fracción y como
decimal entonces veamos aquí tenemos una
décima acá dos décimas acá tres décimas
entonces tenemos cero una décima dos
décimas tres décimas y entre cada décima
vemos que tenemos divisiones vemos que
tenemos diez secciones iguales aquí es
una dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve y diez entonces cada una de
estas rayas representa una centésima tu
puedes ver esto como una décima y luego
tenemos una dos
es 4 56 centésimas entonces podríamos
ver a este punto a este punto de aquí
como una décima y seis centésimas
ahora vamos a escribirlo si lo escribo
como decimal tendríamos lo siguiente 0.1
que sería una décima
seis centésimas entonces tenemos aquí 16
centésimas podemos contarlas
cada una de estas rayas representa una
centésima entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 16 centésimas
solo recuerda que cada una de estas de
estas rayas representa una centésima
entonces 16 centésimas es lo que tenemos
aquí ahora la mayoría de la gente cuando
ve este número no va a decir que este
número es una decena y seis centésimas
simplemente dirá que son 16 centésimas y
como vamos a escribir 16 centésimas en
forma de fracción lo que hacemos es
escribir 16
centésimas 16 sobre 100 hagamos otro
ejemplo hagamos este otro ejemplo dice
el cuadrado grande debajo representa un
entero expresa el área de color como una
fracción y como un decimal entonces
debemos que el entero está dividido en
100 cuadrados iguales entonces cada uno
de estos cuadrados representa una
centésima así que cuántas centésimas
están coloreadas veamos aquí tenemos 10
centésimas 20 centésimas 30 centésimas
40 50 60 70 80 centésimas y 123 45 67
centésimas entonces voy a escribir aquí
en total son 87 centésimas esto fue en
forma fracción ahora para escribirlo en
forma decimal
hay varias maneras puedes escribir ocho
décimas que es lo mismo escribir 80 cm
y más y siete centésimas y 87 centésimas
otra manera de pensar en esto es ver a
cada fila representada como décimas
entonces aquí tenemos una décima dos
décimas tres décimas cuatro décimas
cinco décimas seis décimas siete décimas
ocho décimas y una dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete centésimas así que así que de
cualquier forma esto es 87 centésimas y
ocho décimas y siete centésimas y
terminamos